finally a day off
i haven't gotten to watch tv in forever
up next on mtv
well i think that obviously if you're an
intellectual you can see that rise of
skywalker
is the best movie in the franchise
possibly one of the greatest science
fiction films
or pieces of media ever created i mean
it far surpasses the work of frank
herbert
i'm telling you depressing
no you are not gonna make me watch this
again
you are my queen what is this bad
fantasy tv
hour you are my queen i don't know what
else i can
there's plenty you could say
somebody is messing with me
what
[Music]
no no
[Music]
no
all right enough
[Music]
you know on occasion i do leave the
confines of my unending eternal library
which is contained inside of a parallel
dimension in which only i can
enter and when i do i occasionally watch
television it's kind of weird to think
that it's been a whole year since d
and d stabbed the final jagged knife
into the giant pile of steaming sentient
gargantuan
that was game of thrones it really does
feel like almost yesterday
as we all watch collectively as what
could have been the greatest final
season in television history
crumbled into a thousand pieces and sank
into the bottom of the ocean like so
many pieces of burning ships into the
bottom of blackwater bay
who could have seen it coming
to be honest i knew the season was gonna
be bad i was not
prepared for how bad it was going to be
i was not prepared to be so affected by
it
if you go back and watch my review of
season 8 episode 5 i'm basically raving
like a lunatic because there is
bad and then there's just offensive
disgusting
careless soulless and whatever other
words you can think to throw in there
it's so unbelievably clear that these
writers absolutely did not give a [ __ ]
about this story or these characters so
let's talk about john and danny's
relationship
okay i'm just gonna say this romance
never worked
it was the most awkward and cringy
bullcrap i had ever seen from the get-go
kit harrington and emilia clark had
absolutely no chemistry whatsoever on
screen
you can't make a romance convincing if
the actors look like they want to vomit
when they're kissing
it just doesn't work but even beyond
that
what else did they do to make the
relationship convincing
jack like what do they even have in
common
and i'm feigning incredulity of course
because there's actually a lot that they
have in common
thrust into leadership at young ages
isolated from the happenings in the
greater part of westeros both navigating
a brutal moral landscape
in a society that makes no concessions
to the weak they've both
even got badass magical pets but does
the show bother to go into this do we
ever see them having a heart to heart
about the commonalities involved in
their past and personal struggles
no not that i can remember they tell us
that they are in love but never show us
why they are in love i'm gonna be honest
in general i'm not a big fan of romance
story lines in books movies and
television
i feel like it's been done a million
times and there are usually story
aspects that are
infinitely more interesting that being
said
initially when i found myself disliking
the danny and john romance i thought
it was just me and my personal taste but
as the show went on
and they continued to not develop the
relationship
and as the awkwardness of it all
continued to not dissipate
i realized that it wasn't just me john
and danny's relationship
actually really really
sucked and was not believable or
interesting in the slightest
first of all it all happens too fast
we all know that any consideration of
time or pacing went out the window
after like season six but john and
danny's relationship is still
exceptional i have no idea how long they
knew each other or were together
it seems like a very short amount of
time but by the end of season seven
she seems way more concerned about jon
snow than her own
dragon her child that she just watched
die trying to protect her
she stares off the wall at the haunted
forest and i'm thinking oh she misses
her dragon
but then i realize no she's just worried
about
jon a man who has been in her life for a
few months at the longest
i just don't effing get it when you
actually break things down
and look at them game of thrones had
hours of available time to establish
jon and danny's relationship and make it
truly believable
relationships on tv don't have to take
20 episodes to develop necessarily
tag ned stark and catelyn stark for
instance this is a relationship that
only existed for one season
and is established within a matter of
episodes certainly by the end of episode
three you understand
that there is deep love between the two
characters they care deeply for each
other
and understand each other in ways that
other characters don't
and now let's move on to another example
john
and ingrid we see the full development
of this relationship
over two seasons and it's infinitely
more believable than john and danny's
relationship
in every way imaginable when egret fires
her
arrows at jon snow you absolutely
believe that she is doing it because she
loves him and he has betrayed her
and the pain is so unbearable that the
only way egret knows to make it stop is
by killing jon snow the object of her
love
and each of those arrows inside of jon
snow is symbolic of the pain he felt
because of the fact that he was hurting
the person that he loved more than
anyone else
and then later when he is forced to
watch the woman that he loves die within
his arms he feels responsible for it
although he did not fire the arrow which
killed her
now compare that to danny's death when
john
literally kills daenerys and she dies in
his arms
i felt nothing and i get the sense that
david and dan thought they were being
clever since the scene is somewhat
aesthetically similar to egret's death
it's like they were expecting the
audience to think oh how powerful
oh how tragic oh how shakespearean
john is forced again to cause the death
of the woman he loved but this is
anything but a shakespearean tragedy
deaths in shakespeare had meaning now
you might have heard me say before that
i'm not the biggest fan of shakespeare
but that doesn't mean that i don't
respect his work take romeo and juliet
for instance
not my favorite shakespeare story again
romance is not my thing i much prefer
macbeth or hamlet but that is not the
point
initially i really hated romeo and
juliet i thought it was really silly to
see two teenagers who just met a few
days ago
act as though they are so deeply in love
that they can't bear to exist without
each other
but then once i understood what
shakespeare was actually doing with
romeo and juliet
it actually made sense to me most people
think romeo and juliet is a tragedy
and it is but it's also a comedy
shakespeare is intentionally calling
attention to how ridiculous it all is
parroting ideas from tragic love stories
of antiquity such as pyramus and thisbe
from the poem metamorphosis by the roman
poet ovitt and the esseaca of xenophon
of ephesus a greek writer who lived
between the second and third century a.d
what i'm getting at here is
whether or not you like romeo and juliet
shakespeare is trying to say something
maybe don't rush into things and risk
everything you have for someone you just
met
because they're probably going to end up
causing your death or something like
that
but the ending of game of thrones is
simply nihilistic
it was empty we aren't left with sadness
or even anger it just
feels hollow as though the writers not
only don't understand the characters
but don't even recognize what it is to
be
human i've read a lot of joseph campbell
in my life
his most famous work the hero with a
thousand faces is all about
humanity's stories what's the point of
stories where do they come from
what makes them resonate in the minds of
the audience why is it that the same
ideas and tropes appear in stores
throughout history
all over the world campbell's book is
one of the most famous works of
comparative mythology
ever created you might have heard the
term hero's journey or
monomyth this is where it comes from if
you're not familiar with the term
this is how joseph campbell defines the
word monomyth
a hero ventures forth from the world
of common day into a region of
supernatural wonder
fabulous forces are there encountered
and a decisive victory is worn the hero
comes back
from this mysterious adventure with the
power to bestow boons on his fellow man
like it or not nearly every tale or
story throughout history that has
withstood
the test of time has followed more or
less
the monomyth which usually can be broken
down into 12 steps
the point is before we get too off topic
stories resonate with people for a
reason
and there is a reason that the ending of
game of thrones i.e john and danny's
relationship did not resonate
and to understand why we have to ask
this
question what were they trying to say
sometimes you have to cause the deaths
of the women that you love and be
forever miserable that's not a story
at least not a good one i am someone who
at least to some extent believes in the
power of subtly altering the collected
minds of humanity in a positive
way through art and i've said this
before
but game of thrones truly had an amazing
opportunity
as the biggest show on tv to inspire us
to teach us
something about ourselves and that
doesn't mean
that the ending shouldn't hurt the truth
is often painful
but game of thrones was not trying to
teach
game of thrones was not trying to say
anything
you want to know the real reason that
john and danny's relationship does not
resonate
not really there is one thing that it
lacks
well more than one thing but one crucial
thing and
it is the same thing that the last
several seasons of game of thrones also
lacked
it is the one thing that connects all
meaningful stories
truth the universal truths that remain
consistent regardless of nationality
gender or race
the ending of game of thrones was
desolate of meaning
dany's death was something completely
hollow
disguised as something deep and not well
disguised i might add
david and dan's portrayal of john and
danny's love
is not just bad it's cynical to the
point of being
almost evil okay i should calm down
it's not like any of this really matters
anyway
it's not like anything really matters
no one even cares about this i certainly
don't i don't even exist
maybe you don't even exist you ever
think about that no
you didn't uh
okay that's enough tv for the next 12
months
next on the channel we blast straight
ahead at lightspeed into the classic
sci-fi universe of isaac asimov
as we explore the galactic center the
capital planet of one of the largest
space
empires in science fiction trantor
this one's gonna be fun guys also i
wrote a horror fantasy graphic novel and
it's over four thousand percent its
funding goal on indiegogo
help us get to our next stretch goal
link in the description
[Music]
you